janina ich habe mich heute auf gericht
über christian drosten da virologen der
berliner charité denn in seinem neuen
podcast hat christian drosten gesagt er
rechne mit bis zu 100.000 mehr toten in
deutschland aufgrund der steigenden
fallzahlen der korona pandemie sie sind
schlimmer dran als vor einem jahr sagte
drost und deswegen forderte er auch
kontakt beschränkungen postens podcast
parolen sind so etwas wie eine mischung
aus polka lips no und armageddon nach
dem motto das ende ist nah christian
drosten das ist übrigens der virologe
der noch vor drei monaten gesagt hat die
meisten menschen werden im herbst brot
keine auffrischungsimpfung brauchen das
sei alles okay mit diesem zweiten
schutzstoffe die schutzwirkung der
aktuellen corona impfstoffe die sei viel
stärker als bei der grippe jetzt sagt er
drei monate später wir müssen die lücken
schließen das gelte auch für die doppelt
geimpfte und sein ziel sei eine dreifach
durch geimpfte bevölkerung welcher
schwenk innerhalb nur von drei monaten
was kommt als nächstes schulschließung
ich finde das geht garnicht kontakt
beschränkungen das geht auch nicht ich
finde von politik beratern und das ist
herr drosten dena berät die
bundesregierung in diesen fragen kann
man erwarten und er war sich dass sie
alles tun und konzepte suchen wir weiter
uns öffnen können wie der geschäfte
öffnen können wie die schule offenhalten
können die kinder wieder zur schule
gehen können und auch dort bleiben und
masken frei am unterricht teilnehmen
könnt und auch wie wir unseren sozialen
erlebnisse auch weiter positiv gestalten
können und nicht von neuen kontakt
beschränkung lesen und nicht geht es
darum angst und panik machen die parolen
zu verbreiten wir draußen das in seinen
neuen podcast eben tut denn damit macht
er genau das was er seinen gegnern
vorwirft er verbreitet schlag sein und
sonst nichts
ich habe mich heute doch in england
informieren bevor haben die sendung
begann und da sieht es ganz anders aus
man hat dort ein freedom day ausgerufen
und alle schienen
gelöst und dann haben sich die
infektionszahlen doch wieder so sehr
beschleunigt dass jetzt alle in einer
mischung aus inzwischen wir ignorieren
die infektionszahlen und wir leben in
freiheit und trotzdem sind die
krankenhäuser voll und die bevölkerung
ist zwischen hoffen und bangen also so
ganz fern liegt die aussage von der
osten nicht wenn man sieht ja wenn man
nach england sieht man aber auch noch
passt andere ist man n sieht nach
england sagt wir haben es einfach gewagt
zuseher einen solchen sogenannten
freedom day einfach zu erklären weil was
sehen wir jetzt uns ist doch gesagt
worden lasst euch im einmal mit johnson
johnson zweimal mit allem anderen und
bei und das ist der rolls royce und dann
ist alles gut jetzt kommt auf einmal der
booster erst nur übrigen für die über
70-jährigen jetzt auf einmal für jeden
und jetzt heißt es auf einmal auch
bayern drost na ja das reicht das nicht
mehr denn der impfstoff das weiß doch
jeder ist nach sechs monaten platt und
wir müssen uns dann wieder impfen lassen
was ist denn die konsequenz davon
drosten sagt auch das wird nicht auf im
nächsten frühjahr sind wir nicht vorbei
wir brauchen einen punkt wo wir sagen
diejenigen die sich nicht impfen lassen
wollen lassen sich nicht impfen und der
rest ist wirklich frei von diesen
bevormundungen die es gibt und
was heißt denn auch jemand ist positiv
getestet das sind natürlich auch
diejenigen die sich haben impfen lassen
da ist der krankheitsverlauf ein anderer
deswegen kann man nicht einfach diese
incidence werte vergleichen mit dem vor
einem jahr aber war es nicht auch die
wissenschaft die in der breite dazu
beigetragen hat ein bisschen mehr licht
in das dickicht der pandemie zu bekommen
aber sind jetzt anderthalb jahren dieser
pandemie in einem dauerlauf und haben ja
zunehmend erkenntnis gewonnen und es
gibt ja mehr als entrosten das gibt es
aber wenn ich mir die aussagen von den
posten von vor drei monaten in einem dpa
interview mit der august angucke da sagt
er wir sind alle durch mit dem zweifach
impfen wir brauchen gar keinen dritten
weg sei jetzt sagt der drei monate
später nur drei monate später sind noch
nicht mal 100 tage er sagt naja mein
ziel ist dass alle sich dreifach impfen
lassen wenn es so ist dass die
wissenschaftler immer mehr wissen und
solche experten sind wir uns ja auch am
anfang erklärt haben masken tragen wäre
ein völliger wahnsinn
das dürfen wir nicht vergessen
das frage ich mich warum ein solcher
erkenntnisgewinn von denen die den
ganzen tag im labor stehen und sonst
wollen sie beschäftigen
würde gern was sagen dazu ja dann aber
genau das spiel von licht ins dunkel
bringt ist doch genau das das stichwort
die die wissenschaft tut ja mitunter
auch so oder bestimmte wissenschaftler
die sich sehr stark exponieren als
hätten sie jetzt quasi den stein der
weisen gefunden und sagen so und so muss
es sein und wenn das nicht passiert dann
haben wir die inzidenz über 2000 über
irgendwas und so und dann stellt sich
vielfach raus das den prognosen die dann
ein paar wochen später völlig anders
allein treten ich glaube es ist ein
fehler dass leute sich immer hinstellen
und sagen genau so wird es kommen wenn
wir nicht das und das machen man sollte
vielleicht ein bisschen wehmut auch mal
zeigen und sagen ja in corona ist ist
neu wir haben ja jetzt kennengelernt
aber wir wissen nicht genau wie sich die
lage jetzt verändert das geschehen ist
eben dynamisch und wenn ich höre ja
angeblich biontech ist so gut dass
schützt auf jahre hinaus jetzt wissen
wir nicht was schützt und jedoch nicht
auf jahre hinaus jetzt ist nach sechs
monaten beginnt schon diese dieser
impfschutz irgendwie sich abzusprechen
relativ kreis und freund von mir hat
jetzt ein antikörpertest gemacht der
wäre genauso wie ich im mai das erste
mal im juni als zweiter mann gibt es kam
das resultat 400 nur noch wo man schon
sagen okay die impfung mit bayern
übrigens beide male war mai und juni
jetzt den antikörper test 400 das ist
glaube ich glaube wenn man richtig gut
geschützte hausen 1000 1200 jahre und da
muss man jetzt schon sagen okay und da
verstehe ich zum beispiel auch viele
viele bürger auch mich als bürgerin das
natürlich auch sagt okay was kommt dann
als nächstes muss ich jetzt alle drei
monate hinterher alle sechs monate und
das mit der demut das ist was was man
auch so gehöre gegen den strich geht
karl lauterbach und das ist das einzige
wofür ich kann leute aber auch schon
respektiere der stand hier im der wahl
zu gescheiterten die stadt viele
kartoffeln im studio und dann haben sie
ihn mit seinen falschen prognosen
konfrontiert das hat karl aut aber auch
mitgemacht das muss man erst mal
mitmachen den größten muss man haben da
habe ich respekt vor aber ich war schon
relativ schockiert wie viele prognosen
dann doch nicht richtig waren und ich
fand auch dass viele wissenschaftler
ehrlich gesagt auch dadurch ja schon
auch ein geschäftsmodell wie man bekannt
wird auch erfunden haben und es wurden
ja auch nicht alle wissenschaftler
gehört das war ja schon rückblicken
schon schwierig für sie ja gerade mein
appell der wissenschaftler breite der
wissenschaft hinzu zu ziehen und sich
nicht nur auf einen oder auf den einen
bekannten zu zu projizieren sondern die
gesamtheit
also das ist jetzt ein großes thema weil
die gesamtheit was ist die gesamtheit
wer wen zählt man dazu aber dennoch
brauchen wir ja einen fahrplan und wir
brauchen verlässlichkeit und diese
verlässlichkeit die muss doch wieder
zurück kommen also ich halte auch die
das festhalten an einem incidents wert
der in vielen fragen noch nicht
abschließend bereinigt ist als eine zahl
die er sorgen macht aber wir müssen doch
tatsächlich uns die hospitalisierung
rate an stellen wir müssen uns anschauen
welche medikamente haben möglicherweise
nebenwirkungen effekte die du im alltag
nimmst da kann ich viele beispiele von
aus meinem umfeld
berichten die dazu führen dass quasi der
der schutz pegel immer weiter sinkt mit
diesen fragen muss man sich
auseinandersetzen darüber reden wir viel
zu wenig das sind für mich punkte die
auch durch die wissenschaft natürlich
viel stärker diskutiert werden müssen
und wir müssen verlässlichkeit geben für
den alltag für das gesellschaftliche
miteinander
denn das was es nicht mehr geben darf
ist locker anteil locker und oder die
ausgrenzung von ungeimpften deshalb bin
ich auch in der tat eher für eine 3g
regelung als in debatte um 2 gähn ja und
was ist nicht mehr geben darf ist dass
die leute sich hinstellen nur angst und
panik verbreiten sind wir müssen wege
aufzeigen wie es geht und gehen kann und
was mich auch ärgert ist diese
geschwindigkeit mit der man da über
seine seiner auch als wissenschaftler
wir draußen über seine gemachten
aussagen hinweg gibt es kann doch nicht
sein dass ich mich vor drei monaten in
stellen und sagen alle sind geschützt
und auf einmal drei monate später sage
ich ohne überhaupt zu referieren weil es
mal für drei monaten gesagt habe april
april jeder braucht auf einmal drei
booster und das ganze endet aber die
erkenntnis zuwachs ist ja auch erst
jeder monat in eine tragen natürlich
aber die erwartungshaltung der menschen
richtig managen und wenn man ihnen immer
diese freedom day karotte vor die nase
hält und das ist für mich mehr an der
gutenachtgeschichte für die kommunen als
realität und wenn wir erst mal abwarten
und sehen was wie wirkt der impfstoff
wie entwickelt es werden noch gar nicht
gesehen wie gut ist denn jetzt der
schutz der menschen durch herbst und
winter wenn man hin rosten jetzt hört
ist der
auf jeden fall besorgniserregend ob denn
alle entsprechend geschützt im herbst
und winter ist wenn man ihn vor drei
monaten gehört hat dann hat man anderen
eindruck garten völlig gegensätzlich und
das ist ein bisschen komisch beim
weingut der erkenntniszuwachs muss man
sagen der impfstoff ist ja noch nicht so
lange verimpft also wir wissen jetzt
gerade mal dass der sechs monate rum
sind